ich hatte heute sehr bewegt dass die
schnelltests league ohne test werden ab
montag geld kosten in den apotheken oder
auch überall sonst ich habe mich gefragt
warum die kostenfreien tests waren fange
ich mit das beste an alkohol politik in
deutschland weil wir früh verstanden
haben dass ich dann natürlich mehr leute
testen lassen jetzt sollen die tests
kostenpflichtig werden ich habe mich
gefragt was und wo die gründe der
politik ich würde natürlich sagen das
ist die leute zugängen es ist ja wie
eine impfpflicht durch die hintertür
weil früher konnte man schnell mal ins
bürgerzentrum nebenan gehen konnten test
machen lassen und mit dem test kann man
dann ins restaurant gehen es darf man
nämlich nicht vergessen man braucht
diese tests zb und mit freunden wenn man
nicht geimpft des abends abendessen zu
gehen jetzt sollen diese tests
kostenpflichtig sein bedeutet im
umkehrschluss ist werden sich viel
weniger menschen testen lassen und die
fälschungen werden ansteigen die test
fälschung werden ansteigen das
gesundheitssystem gewinnt dadurch also
gar nichts wenn wir brauchen menschen
die sich gelassen wollen die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen sollen sie
natürlich testen wie soll das jetzt geld
kosten eine zahl möchte ich noch kurz
benennen bevor wir starten der nächste
lockt dann solltest einen neuen lockdown
geben wird dieser und 52 milliarden euro
kosten das in relation zu den test
eröffne ich gerne die runde also ich bin
total erstaunt ich komme gerade aus
holland ich bezahle schon immer für
meine test ich frage mich auch noch wie
lange noch wieviel umsonst sein muss
weil du sprichst gerade davon dass der
nächste lockdown so und so viel geld
kostet und ich sage die ganze zeit die
so ganz locker und diese ganze krone
politik hat schon sehr viel geld
gekostet wir sollten das alles bezahlen
wenn wir nicht irgendwann mal selbst
verantwortung übernehmen und sagen okay
entweder ich lasse mich impfen oder ich
lass mich eben testen und ich bezahle
dass auch ich stehe dafür ein dass ich
eine entscheidung getroffen habe dann
werden wir in dieser ganz politik auch
keinen schritt weiter kommen der staat
kann einem nicht alles abnehmen wir
haben hier also ich glaube ich eindeutig
als bestrafung von ungeimpften windows
vista so als die ungeimpften dürfen die
geimpften dürfen die restaurants
betreten wie sie wollen und alles
mögliche machen und die ungeimpften
sollen spüren dass sie sich besser
impfen lassen deshalb ist das eingeführt
worden es ist nur alles von vorgestern
ist ja schon eine ganze
reihe von zeit eine ganze zeit lang
geschlossen
jetzt wird es in kraft gesetzt und
eigentlich ist es jetzt unnötig denn wir
wissen ja so heinisch verspätete
information unserer völlig unfähigen
gesundheitsbehörden wirklich dass wir
schon in deutschland 80 prozent doppelt
geimpft sind und 84 einmal eigentlich
sind wir herren nehmen so wie die
holländer auch und wir könnten einen
freedom day haben und dann musst du dich
gar nicht mehr impfen lassen wir da
irgendwo rein gehst und darüber sollten
wir darüber sollten testen und darüber
sollten wir endlich anfangen zu reden
über die neue zeit die vor uns liegt ich
möchte aber auch einer sagen das stimmt
ganz genau aber ich möchte auch einmal
sagen wie denn so eine
impfpflicht durch die hintertür auch
noch aussehen kann meine mutter hat mir
nämlich gerade berichtet von den
kapverdischen inseln wo sich sehr viele
leute die im sogenannten hinterland
leben nicht haben impfen lassen so das
sind meistens leute mit einer
niedrigeren bildung bauern
und wahrscheinlich gesehen auch nicht so
viele menschen sehen auch noch so viele
mensch und das ist irgendwie auch alles
nicht so dramatisch und die hätten auch
durchaus das recht sich nicht impfen zu
lassen aber was dort passiert ist ist
dass man gesagt hat okay leute wir
machen das folgendermaßen wenn ihr euch
nicht impfen lässt dann lassen wir ein
gesetz das ihr nicht in die schulen
gehen könnt ihr dürften also dürften
nicht in hand die die schule ist in die
schule nicht an die universität und so
weiter und so fort jetzt mittlerweile
hast du eine impfquote von an die 90
prozent das für das ganze hat total
funktioniert ich bin da ein bisschen
über berater erpresser aber ja so kann
es auch aussehen dagegen ist
unbezahlt an test von 30 euro
ich meine wir haben jetzt um die 15
prozent die sich nicht impfen lassen wir
wissen wenig über diese leute wir wissen
nicht ob sie aus sozioökonomischen
zustände kommen wo diese aufklärung
nicht nicht vorhanden ist ob es um
etliche im pfarrheim zum beispiel aus
ganz normalen vereine sind ganz normale
leute ist denkt man nicht mehr
öffentlich
entschuldigen davon scheint
den staaten angekommen ist werden aber
ist also das ist keine homogene gruppe
ja ein sehr unterschiedlicher menschen
ich weiß auch dass wir probleme auch mit
migranten haben mit flüchtlinge mit
denen ich arbeite
das sind die fair use und die
verschwörungstheorien die angst auch
sehr sehr hoch da mussten wir in energie
investieren um aufzuklären um diese
leute einfach dazu zu bewegen sich zu
impfen und nicht immer diese gruppe als
die gegner als diejenigen die jetzt
menschen umbringen das ist keine
homogene gruppe die wir haben oder wir
fangen einfach schon mal an und
stigmatisieren sie nicht länger und
sollte sie endlich in ruhe lassen es
in ruhe lassen
nein wir sind ja geimpft sollen die uns
gefährden wie denn ich lasse mich im
november zum zum dritten mal impfen und
dann denke ich mal wer will man da noch
irgendwas theoretisch kann ich noch
richtig krank werden das weiß ich wohl
aber theoretisch kann ich immer krank
werden und ich fürchte mich gar nicht
mehr schon seit ich habe mich noch nie
richtig gefürchtet vor diesen
geschichten aber jetzt schon mal gar
nicht mehr und ungeimpfte jagen mir
keinen schrecken ein lasst sie doch
verdammt noch mal in ruhe mit uns leben
es ist ja nur noch eine kleine gruppe
und es ist genau richtig ich kenne ein
paar die haben sehr honorige grund ist
weder rechtsradikalen noch irgendwie vor
ort sondern die haben ihre gründe zu
sagen ich bin ich traue dem impfstoff
nicht ich bin nicht ganz sicher ob ich
da nicht später langzeitschäden von habe
wie auch immer sollen die halt glauben
und sich entsprechend verhalten aber
mehr karte einen punkt auf den will ich
auch noch mal zu sprechen kommen
spannend findet dieses selbst wahrnehmen
und gerade in deutschland der staat muss
alles bezahlen es wird hier völlig
vergessen mittlerweile was der staat
denn hier in deutschland alles schon für
uns gemacht wird und wer bezahlt sind am
ende des tages auch hier ja aber
dann hat man den wie wahnsinnig viel
gehe in diesem lande gemacht wurde im
vergleich zu ganz anderen ländern und
das geht mir immer so ein bisschen auf
den senkel jetzt wird auch weiter
gefallen er der staat muss der staat
muss der staat oder wir müssen hier
müssen wir müssen den staat vor dass
auch einer gewissen also ich bin total
ich bin wenn ich ehrlich bin ich bin
komplett dagegen dass impfausweise im
restaurant vorgezeigt werden müssen ist
es vorgezeigt werden müssen bei der
aktion im vorfrühling day und alle
beschränkungen rauert wird wohl stark
fordert von denjenigen ihr müsst ein
testfahrzeug oder ein im haus als es ist
eine pflicht das war ja auch foto- oder
nicht so dass du nur ins restaurant
gehen konnte ist deswegen und ja aber
das war gerade mal verreisen was es
kosten würde also ich meine jetzt noch
mal ein halbes dreiviertel jahr ein
bisschen die nerven machten halt auch
die regierung sonst ich glaube auch
nicht dass wir den zweiten lok dann
gebraucht hätten also ich bin nicht der
überzeugung dass alles richtig war mit
blick auf die letzten
ja aber ganz so schön wer aus dem
bürgermeister haushalt auskommen weiter
nach öffentlichen also wenn du hast
sicher als
medizin experten ja durchaus auch zeigen
können im vorfeld und empfinde diese im
moment ist aber die rede wenigstens in
der öffentlichkeit schon seit früher
letzten jahres so und habe nicht später
erst auf den zug aufgesprungen also ich
habe das auch schon gemacht als man
wirklich hart angefasst wurde ich ja
immer aber
nicht drin nicht respekt habe ich sagen
und wenn der staat wirklich spielt ja
aber mit dem horrorszenario lockt doch
nicht mein wo er habe ich diese zahl er
spielt mit dem horrorszenario wenn der
staat also davon überzeugt ist dass wir
vielleicht wieder einen neuen lockdown
brauchen werden jens spahn sagt er nein
wenn der staat glaubt dass es passieren
könnte dann muss er doch jetzt ganz klar
auf wegen wirtschaftlicher wie auch
unternehmer aufregen würde oder glaubst
du dass die menschen sich genauso im
fall so genau so testen lassen werden
wie vorher wenn sie dafür geld sein
müssen das glaube ich nicht
wahrscheinlich werden ist sehr sehr
viele dann nicht machen auch die leute
leid die gerade jobs gefunden haben in
den impfzentren den ginster zumindest es
gibt aber auch minimale gewinne also mit
der ganzen in der indoor ganzmann wie
das ist also dann eben doch eher
langsamen schlechte karten vor bei mir
geht es aber nur darum dieses gefühl der
staat muss für mich alles bezahlen alles
machen geben das ist das ist das was mir
auf den senkel geht sondern in der tat
außer ich habe medizinische gründe ist
nicht zu machen das ist jedem offen
gestellt
haben und sicherlich auch regel
vielleicht sollte der stadt uns auch in
ruhe lassen eher psychologisch sollte
sie uns ermöglichen mit unserer ängste
und mit dieser krankheit auch klar zu
kommen ohne dass sie uns 1000
vorschriften bis heute also deshalb bin
ich auch zufrieden ich bin dafür zu
sagen wir haben es geschafft lasst uns
normal leben wir müssen diese normalität
wieder gewinnen und wie immer noch nicht
daran wir müssen auch lernen jetzt aus
diesen alten debatten rauszukommen ich
kann nur sagen für mich gilt das
lauterbach land ist abgebrannt den will
ich nicht mehr sehen kann ich nicht mehr
sagt könnte problematisch werden
wird nicht drin sitzen
der ist ja der schrecken seiner eigenen
partei also man hat es ja gesehen hat
sich auf diesen gruppenfoto zusammen
standen und wurden fotografiert er war
ganz am rand der druck als 1 jahr eine
maske das sagt schon alles die wollen
mit ihm natürlich nichts zu tun haben
und wenn die mit einer neuen regierung
anfangen wollen jedoch kein
gesundheitsminister da sitzen haben ja
nur noch rückwärts argumentiert die
wären ja verrückt nämlich lauterbach
wird nichts er hat sich offenbar auch
schon testen lassen für eine comedy show
das für mich interessant macht mit
wichtig dass wir gut aufgehoben
[Musik]